when they moved out they are making
something like five or six hundred
million dollars a year revenue when we
started our company when I started this
company the first office that I had did
you ever go to that one I've been to it
okay Craigslist so the first office I
had we didn't have a lot of money and I
moved we I started me and see Avon my
friend week week old least in office in
the Inner Sunset which is a non popular
neighborhood in San Francisco but it's
lovely it just looked like an apartment
it was a house that they that was zoned
mixed-use and when we went to visit it
there was a sign that said Craigslist
1996 to 2000 and whenever we moved in 15
or 16 or 17 I forget my portion of the
rent was $500 which was a lot of money
at the time and because we had just said
the business we only were making 30
grand a month and we move in and there
was a desk still in one of the rooms and
this was like a it wasn't a shitty
apartment but it kind of was a shitty
apartment yeah it was a three bedroom
apartment less than 1,000 square feet
and I move in and Craig from Craigslist
Craig Newark he actually left his desk
there and his desk was a kitchen table
that was his desk
but it was too heavy to move and so he
just covered there so that's what I use
and the Landlord I came in his name was
Emanuel I believe he came in and I was
like hey so crazy see here he's like
yeah Craig started the oh he lived on
the street in coal Valley he started the
company here from 96 up until recently I
go oh what was that like this again
they're kind of like little celebrities
in the neighborhood everyone knew about
him and at a time when they moved out
they were making something like five or
six hundred million dollars a year
president and this a whole apartment my
half of the rent was five hundred
dollars see Amos was like mm so we pitch
one hundred dollars and it could only
see at most 12
people probably and that was extreme
that was the Craigslist team and I go
home or they lightens I call they were a
cool Craig told every one of you tippy
interest like you might talk to me and
I'd be like pretty what's your job here
he would say he owns it but he's the
founder he would say I need customer
service for Craigslist nice and they
were so DISA they were so cheap and
frugal that in the lease it said
something like Emmanuel had to give them
pull up paper each month and every once
in a while he would forget or not bring
it one time and they wouldn't pay the
rent until he got the toilet paper yeah
if you just close your eyes and imagine
the Craigslist website and then start to
imagine an apartment or a house it
looked like that it looked like the UI
of the site yeah and if you google
Craigslist office you'll see photos of
it they had a big sign on it it was
great and did you repeat him yeah so I
hold the email them Craig and we talked
back and forth I thought we were fun a
little bit and I was like hey can you
come and take a picture with me at the
office and he never made it over but we
did talk and I we correspond everyone so
long it was awesome and all I'm doing to
build how Craigslist makes money they
make money only from jobs jobs is in
cars all in certain markets yeah and
then everything else free they make like
five million dollars a year that way and
they've never bought a company they only
employ at this point probably thirty
people so they just must it must be one
most profitable companies in the world
[Music]